autopsy reports usually confirm what's
already known about a celebrity's death
but some reveal secrets that the public
and in at least one case the celebrity
themselves may not have known
just take a look at these fans who spent
the night out here mourning the loss of
Paul Walker Paul Walker died as a
passenger in a car driven by his friend
Roger Rodas on November 30th 2013. the
vehicle collided with a Lamppost and two
trees in the San Fernando Valley suburb
of Valencia California after striking
the second tree the car burst into
flames and both Walker and rotis were
declared dead by Los Angeles County
firefighters who arrived on the scene
while it was believed that Walker died
as a result of the Collision a report
from the Los Angeles County Coroner
showed that the 40-year-old suffered a
far more agonizing fate as the report
Reveals His body was found lying across
the passenger seat of the car Walker had
suffered extensive thermal injuries
including charred skin and fractured
bones that according to the medical
examiner were heat related soot was
found in his trachea which indicated
that he was able to breathe and was
therefore alive while the car was on
fire his bloodstream also had 14 carbon
monoxide saturation 12 percent higher
than normal levels the report ultimately
cited traumatic and thermal injuries as
the cause of Walker's death
it was a tragic end to an acclaimed
career oscar-winning actor Philip
Seymour Hoffman was found dead from a
drug overdose at the age of 46 on
February 2nd 2014. as his longtime
partner costume designer Mimi O'Donnell
noted in an essay for Vogue Hoffman had
struggled with substance abuse during
his college years after that he remained
sober for decades before experiencing
several personal struggles that led to a
relapse followed by a return to
treatment in 2013. in late February 2014
the New York Medical examiner's Office
issued its findings in a report which
stated that Hoffman's death was the
result of an accidental overdose caused
by acute mixed drug intoxication a
combination of various narcotics
including heroin cocaine amphetamines
and benzodiazepines may have been taken
sequentially in a relatively short
period chronic drug users may not feel
the immediate effects of substances so
they will mix more drugs in order to
produce a high as chief medical
correspondent for CNN Dr Sanjay Gupta
said in a 2014 interview they're not
feeling it but it's still having an
impact on their ability to breathe and
that's the real problem
on January 9 2022 comedian and Full
House star Bob Saget was found
unresponsive in a hotel room in Orlando
Florida the 65 year old was pronounced
dead on the scene of what was initially
reported to be blunt force trauma to the
Head the Orange County Sheriff's Office
conducted an investigation and relayed
their findings to sagitt's family who
issued a statement in February of that
year the family wrote they have
concluded that he accidentally hit the
back of his head on something thought
nothing of it and went to sleep his
family went on to clarify that no drugs
or alcohol were involved the New York
Times also noted that the Sheriff's
Office dismissed any suggestion of Foul
Play the autopsy report gave a more
detailed account to the extent of
Saget's injuries Dr Joseph Stephanie the
chief medical examiner for orange and
Osceola counties wrote that he suffered
a serious blow to the Head one that
caused fractures to the back right side
and front of his skull the blow also led
to vein rupture which caused blood to
pool in the space between the brain and
the surrounding membrane Stephanie
concluded that the injuries were most
likely caused by a fall though a New
York Times article shared observations
from medical professionals who
questioned the idea that Saget would
have gone to sleep after experiencing
such an injury
on March 23 2016 emmy-winning comedian
Gary shanling told a doctor friend that
he was experiencing pain in his legs and
shortness of breath the friend advised
him to seek medical attention but
channeling was hesitant when his
condition failed to improve the
following day shamling called 9-1-1 and
collapsed during the call he was rushed
to St John's Hospital in Santa Monica
California where he was pronounced dead
at the age of 66. Gary is gone and this
just doesn't seem real shandling's death
was initially reported as a heart attack
but the Los Angeles County coroner's
office opened an investigation to
determine the actual cause the office
issued their findings in December 2016
which noted that a toxicology report
found only therapeutic amounts of Xanax
and opiates in his system which stmz
noted were prescribed for then recent
dental work the report also found that
shanling had died from a pulmonary
embolism caused by a blood clot in his
lungs the clot also known as deep vein
thrombosis developed in his legs during
a trip to Hawaii which was when he had
first reported feeling unwell according
to the Centers for Disease Control and
prevention blood clots form when
individuals must travel while sitting in
a confined space such as a flight in
many cases the clots dissolve on their
own but some break apart and move to the
lungs causing a pulmonary embolism
actor Tyler Sanders impressive list of
television credits include a starring
role on the Amazon series just add magic
mystery City and guest appearances on
9-1-1 Lone Star and Fear The Walking
Dead all of which he'd achieved while
still a teenager unfortunately Sanders
also struggled with both depression and
substance abuse the latter of which
contributed to his untimely death at the
age of 18. Sanders was found dead in his
Los Angeles home on June 16 2022 six
months later the Los Angeles Department
of medical examiner coroner issued its
findings the report noted that Sanders
had a history of drug use and that he
informed a friend the night before his
death that he had reported using
fentanyl the same friend found Sanders
at his home and called paramedics who
pronounced the actor dead drug
paraphernalia was visible and identified
at the scene medical examiner Robin
Parks wrote in the report that fentanyl
which is a synthetic opioid can be 50 to
100 times as potent as the
pharmaceutical paint killer morphine she
included based on the history
circumstances and examination as I
currently know them the manner of death
is accidental
on August 5th 2022 daytime emmy-winning
actor Anne Heche was involved in a
series of vehicular accidents before
colliding with a house that caused both
the car she was driving and the building
to catch fire it took firefighters 45
minutes to extricate haish from the
vehicle during which she suffered both
severe burns and smoke inhalation and
even if they'd known for certain someone
was in the wrecked car it probably would
not have changed what happened treatment
at an area Hospital in Burn Center
revealed that the extent of the damage
included a traumatic brain injury after
lapsing into a coma haish was declared
legally dead on August 11th law
enforcement officials stated at the time
of the accident that haish was under the
influence of Narcotics and a preliminary
blood analysis appeared to show the
presence of cocaine and other substances
in her system however a report issued on
December 6 2022 from the Los Angeles
County Department of medical examiner
coroner revealed that only an inactive
element of cocaine and marijuana were
found in her system this meant that she
had not used either substance at the
time of the crash the official cause of
death was listed as smoke inhalation and
thermal injuries with first degree Burns
covering over 40 percent of her body
hash also suffered a sternal fracture
which made it difficult for her to
breathe and according to the coroner's
office contributed significantly to her
death
fans of Anton Yelchin were stunned by
news of the Star Trek actor's death in
2016. the young star died after his own
car pinned him against a security fence
at his home in Studio City California a
police investigation and subsequent
report from the Los Angeles County
coroner's office found that the
27-year-old actor died as a result of
blunt traumatic asphyxia or intense
compression of his chest the report
suggested that at 1am on June 19 2016
Yelchin may have stepped out of his 2015
Jeep Grand Cherokee to check his gate or
mail the vehicle which was parked on a
steep incline on his driveway may not
have been properly parked and it rolled
backward crushing him against a brick
fence pillar in the gate the report
stated that yelchin's death was
accidental and took place within a
minute after the car struck him CBS News
noted in 2016 that 850 000 Vehicles the
majority of which were 2014 and 2015
Jeep Grand Cherokees were under
investigation by the national highway
traffic safety administration because of
their electronic gear shift yilchin's
family settled a wrongful death lawsuit
against Fiat Chrysler automobiles for
undisclosed terms in 2018.
the legacy of the popular emmy-winning
musical comedy drama series Glee was
tempered by the fact that three of its
cast members died Naya Rivera was one of
those actors who played cheerleader
Santana Lopez on the series she died
while spending time with her
four-year-old son at California's Lake
Piru on July 8 2020. a report from the
Ventura County Medical Examiner revealed
that Rivera and her son Josie were
swimming in Lake Piru after helping her
son back into their rented boat Rivera
was unable to return to the craft the
report stated that her son saw her
struggle and call for help before
disappearing into the water her body was
found five days later on July 13 2020.
according to the report Rivera suffered
from vertigo and had small amounts of
the anti-anxiety medication diazepam in
her system along with an appetite
suppressant neither of these was cited
as a factor in her death however which
was instead attributed solely to
Accidental drowning
actor Michael K Williams overcame a
debilitating struggle with substance
abuse to become a powerful presence in
numerous acclaimed television series he
is known for roles like the vengeful
Omar little in The Wire powerful
gangster Albert chalky white and
Boardwalk Empire and his emmy-nominated
turn is Montrose Freeman in Lovecraft
country Williams was also dedicated to
supporting individuals especially young
people through non-profits like his
making kids win initiative why is this
not here for my young people my children
there's nothing for them to do
additionally he explored the
circumstances that often brought young
people to the drug trade and juvenile
justice system through emmy-nominated
documentaries like the Vice news series
Black Market tragically Williams was
found dead at the age of 54 in his
Brooklyn apartment on September 6 2021 a
report from the New York City office of
the chief medical examiner found that
Williams had died of acute drug
intoxication after using heroin laced
with the synthetic opioid Fentanyl and
an analog para Flora fentanyl his death
was ruled accidental fans and co-stars
alike paid tribute to Williams in 2023
the U.S attorney's Office for the
southern district of New York reported
that Irvin Cartagena part of the drug
trafficking organization that sold
heroin to Williams pleaded guilty to
charges of conspiring to distribute
narcotics
authorities were called to the home of
Cameron Boyce on the afternoon of July 6
2019 after the actor was found
unresponsive Boyce who was best known
for shows such as Jesse and Disney's
Descendants was pronounced dead on the
scene shocking fans and co-stars alike
while tributes poured in on social media
the Los Angeles County coroner's office
performed an autopsy officials were
reluctant to release a cause of death
due to a need for further investigation
the coroner's report issued on July 30th
2019 noted that boys suffered from
epilepsy and that his death was natural
and caused by a seizure related to the
condition a statement from his family
corroborated that finding adding that he
died in his sleep from Sudden Unexpected
death in epilepsy according to the
Centers for Disease Control and
prevention this little-known condition
affects approximately one out of every 1
000 individuals with epilepsy the exact
cause is not known but the CDC explains
the death may occur when a seizure
causes an interruption to breathing
patterns or heart rhythm
South African model turned actor Charles
B Dean was on the brink of stardom
thanks to a role in the 2022 Palm Door
winning film triangle of sadness but her
Ascent was cut short on August 29 2022
when her representation reported that
she had died of a sudden and unexpected
illness at a New York City Hospital her
cause of death wasn't revealed until
December of that year when a
spokesperson from the New York Medical
examiner's Office stated that the 32
year old died of bacterial sepsis the
examiner's office revealed that Dean who
also had a recurring role as cyanide on
Black Lightning had been infected by
capnocytophasia a bacterium commonly
found in both animals and humans the
bacteria is related to a variety of
health problems and in certain cases it
can cause serious illnesses the
examiner's office reported that the
sepsis occurred because Dean was
vulnerable to infections after having
her spleen removed following a 2009 car
accident in Cape Town that same accident
also left her with multiple broken bones
and a collapsed lung
the circumstances surrounding the 1981
death of Natalie Wood continue to
Fascinate Classic Hollywood and True
Crime devotees alike the oscar-nominated
actor drowned while on a boat trip with
her husband Robert Wagner on November 29
1981 an autopsy report issued at the
time by Los Angeles County Coroner
Thomas naguchi cited accidental drowning
and hypothermia as the cause of her
death the report also noted superficial
skin bruises on the extremities and
abrasions on the left side of her face
these were attributed to injuries
sustained at the time of woods drowning
a number of prescription drugs were
found in her system including the
painkiller Darvin medication to combat
seasickness and insomnia and two
unidentified pills The Superficial
injuries on Wood's Body remained a
pressing question for those who believed
there was more to her demise than
drowning when the Los Angeles County
Sheriff's Office reopened the inquiry in
2011 these bruises and other marks were
suggested as supporting evidence that
wood may have been injured prior to
entering the water as a result the cause
of death was changed to drowning and
other undetermined factors though no
conclusive evidence of another cause was
or has yet to be presented Natalie Wood
was also loved by a world full of
audiences
and they too will miss her
cult movie fans remember actor Yvette
Vickers as the star of such 50 science
fiction favorites as attack of the
50-foot woman and attack of the Giant
Leeches the actor and former Playboy
Playmate achieved a greater if more
tragic notoriety and death when she was
found at her Beverly Hills Home on April
27 2011. a concerned neighbor who noted
that the 82 year old Vickers had not
been seen for several months entered the
actor's house and found her remains
which were in an advanced state of
decomposition according to a report by
the Los Angeles County coroner's office
the cause of Vicar's death was heart
disease however the body was so
decomposed that the coroner's office
described it as appearing to be
mummified in fact it was in a state of
decay so Advanced that initially it was
impossible to determine whether the body
was male or female eventually dental
records helped to confirm that the body
was that of Vicars but the exact date of
death was impossible to determine
Lieutenant Tony Carranza of the Los
Angeles Police Department told ABC News
once you start to have decomposition it
becomes more difficult but it looks like
it's probably six months it's hard to
say
fans of Steven twitch boss experienced
shock and dismay upon learning of his
death by self-inflicted gunshot wound
according to the Los Angeles County
medical examiner's report no other
factors contributed to his death on
December 13 2022 which was confirmed as
a suicide The 40-Year-Old dancer and
Ellen Degeneres Show DJ did not have any
drugs or alcohol in his system and his
body showed no other signs of trauma or
wounds additionally boss's wife dancer
and choreographer Alison holker told law
enforcement that her husband did not
have a history of suicide attempts or
suicidal ideation she also confirmed
that he did not have any mental health
problems or financial or marital issues
that might have contributed to a suicide
Stephen was an incredible father
an incredible husband
a frequent guest star and recurring
player on numerous television series
actor Heath Freeman appeared on ER NCIS
and Without a Trace he also enjoyed a
three-episode Arc between 2005 and 2007
as the sadistic serial killer Howard
Epps on Bones sadly Freeman earned more
headlines for his untimely death at the
age of 41 on November 14 2021. the actor
was pronounced dead after being found
unresponsive in his home in Austin Texas
several months later the Travis County
Medical Examiner made public its
findings in an autopsy report TMZ
published the report on March 9 2022
which revealed that he died of a
combination of alcohol narcotics and
prescription medication among the drugs
found in Freeman's system at the time of
the autopsy were fentanyl cocaine
oxycodone hydrocodone and Alprazolam
which is better known by the brand name
Xanax the report also noted that police
discovered both Xanax and Oxycodone
pills at Freeman's home opiates like
oxycodone and benzodiazepines like Xanax
are dangerous and potentially lethal
when combined with alcohol while
fentanyl is a highly potent drug that
carries a strong risk of fatal overdose
if you or anyone you know needs help
with addiction issues help is available
visit the Substance Abuse and Mental
Health Services Administration website
or contact samhsa's National helpline at
1-800-662-help 1-800-662-4357